l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est au président
christian jacob
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je n'imaginais pas à la
semaine dernière en demandant au premier
ministre si et quand il allait
démissionner que nous allions nous
réveiller une semaine plus tard avec si
jolie deux démissions pour le prix d'une
celle de françois hollande dont on nous
dit qu'il a pris la grande et belle
décision d'un homme d'état en vérité il
a acté sa rupture profonde avec les
français et l'échec cuisant de son
quinquennat
des missions aussi d'un premier ministre
qui tente de faire oublier qu'il a
gouverné la moitié du quinquennat qu'il
est co responsable du fiasco total de la
gauche
un premier ministre qui a éliminé
méthodiquement tous ceux qui le gênait
pour en citer que quelques-uns monsieur
ayrault monsieur montebourg
madame taubira et et tout cela bien
entendu avant de neutraliser le
président de la république lui-même il
laisse la gauche en ruine son camp en
lambeaux et la france dans l'état que
l'on sait c'est dans ce contexte
institutionnel délétère que vous prenez
vos fonctions monsieur le premier
ministre si j'ai bien compris en
récompense des services rendus
les français savent que vous ne ferez
rien ou presque dans les quelques
semaines qui nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle ils savent bien c'est le
dernier gouvernement de françois
hollande ne fera pas en quatre mois ce
qu'il a été incapable de faire en quatre
ans mais question sont donc simples
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est votre légitimité politique
pour gérer les affaires courantes avez
été vous ici dans cet hémicycle une
majorité et allez vous
et allez vous soumettre au vote de
l'assemblée nationale
votre déclaration de politique générale
si vous n'avez pas de doute sur la
majorité vous allez le faire
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre bernard cazeneuve
merci
musique motion président jacob
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour la manière très bienveillante
absolument aimable avec laquelle vous
avez eu la gentillesse de me souhaiter
la bienvenue
ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur surtout
surtout lorsque l'on sait à quel bilan
vous adosser vous même votre
appréciation pour me condamner avant
même que je vais commencer à agir alors
monsieur le président jacques plé
s'émeut pas vous dire très simplement
quelques mots là brad jacobs et l'ouvrir
cvo plex est que le président de la
république a pris une décision et cette
décision il a prise en conscience et est
langage et je voudrais devant l'ensemble
de la représentation nationale rendre
hommage au président de la république
pour la hauteur de vue qui a toujours
été la sienne pour le sens de l'état qui
l'a toujours caractérisé
je voudrais rendre hommage aussi au
président de la république pour la
parole élevé qui a été la sienne et qui
contraste singulièrement avec ce que je
viens d'entendre et je voudrais aussi
rendre hommage au président de la
république pour avoir eu le courage
pendant tout ce quinquennat qui va se
poursuivre dans l'action pour avoir tué
ces régions dont le pays avait besoin en
rétablissant la compétitivité des
entreprises et en prenant les mesures
pour cela qu'ils devaient être prises
alors que la compétitivité des
entreprises et est en berne et que le
chômage ne cessé d'augmenter à l'époque
où françois fillon était premier
ministre de la france mise en place du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi qui
permet aujourd'hui aux marges des
entreprises être restaurée et qui permet
depuis le début de l'année d'enregistrer
près de 73 mille 500 chômeurs de moi
alors que depuis dix ans nous n'avions
pas connu en france une diminution du
chômage
je veux saluer ce qui a été fait par le
président de la république pour sauver
de grands services publics qui n'avait
cessé d'être abîmés au cours des cinq
années précédentes
qu'il s'agisse de la création de
soixante mille emplois dans l'éducation
nationale
que ce grand service qui permet
l'égalité des chances qui permet à la
méritocratie républicaine de vivre cesse
d'être abîmés alors que vous n'avez
cessé de l'affaiblir au cours du
quinquennat précédent
je voudrais remercier le président de la
république pour avoir eu le courage et
pour avoir eu la lucidité de réhausser
les effectifs et les moyens des forces
de sécurité intérieure alors que vous
l'aviez cessé de les abaisser de les
abîmer
alors même qu'à l'occasion des
discussions sur le livre blanc de la
défense vous aviez vous même pointé
qu'il existait en 9 ie jacob à risque
terroriste mais son lob nous allons je
rends hommage le président de la
république et je rends hommage aussi à
l'action de jean marc ayrault de manuel
valls deux coups de grands premier
ministre qui ont engagé les actions dont
le pays avait besoin et vous me demandez
d'où je tire ma légitimité mais je la
tire est bien entendu monsieur présent
la coop du parlement parce que le
conseil des ministres se réunira samedi
qu'il aura à traiter de la question de
l'état d'urgence qu'il aura traité de ma
déclaration de politique générale et du
vote qui s'ensuivra et qui permettra
soyez en sûrs de vous garantir que je
dispose dans cet hémicycle d'une large
majorité pour vivre l'action dont le
pays a besoin
l'action pour le renforcement des
politiques de l'union européenne pour
protéger les français
l'action dont le pays a besoin pour
assurer la protection de notre pays
contre la menace terroriste
la légitimité la majorité dont nous
avons besoin pour poursuivre l'action de
redressement de nos ponts pour la
solidarité et surtout pour faire en
sorte que les français sachent bien que
cette majorité qui les protègent aura à
débattre projet contre projet face à une
opposition qui veut détruire la
protection sociale et le modèle social
français
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]